foreign
Marin Huron and I am chairing the
meeting today
may I first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
you maintain social distancing from all
other persons whilst in the council
chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you use the hand
sanitizer and the wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and doing any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
also that you do not interrupt other
speakers
and if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
also please ensure your mobile phones
are on silent or Switched Off
additionally this morning we will be
using the e-voting system for this
meeting on the modern gov app
I would like to remind everybody
president that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be informed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you were also consent into being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
now in attendance for this meeting today
we have Melissa Evans head of Finance
Rebecca hurt corporate manager Finance
not Sue Palmer but Jan Robertson our
Deputy monitoring office officer
and also today making a debut we have
Bethany Webb who's our clock for today
for the first time so um well done to
her and we must make sure the meeting
goes well
can I move now to the agenda please
um apologies for abstinence and
substitutions none received a chair
thank you
to receive Declarations of peculiary and
non-procuniary interests by members
sent in thank you
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council petition scheme an
unreceived chair thank thank you and
item four to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of November
first of all are there any points
regarding the accuracy or otherwise
cancer Reborn
um thank you chair on um
page
seventh
um 90 paragraph 98.11
I'd asked about the um saying that the
councilors needed to see the entire risk
picture for the council's companies and
the officer agreed that that would
happen but I just wondered if that could
be noted in the in the minutes because
um
the officer responsible did say that
that would be
appropriate thank you chair and it's not
noted at the minute obviously is it well
we all agreed to that if it was said and
I can remember it um Dave you were
sharing but
it should be in there as a fair point
and we're all agreed on that
yep thank you
anything else regarding to accuracy of
the minutes
all agreed most of you were here last
time yep okay can I have a proposal and
a second to please
okay that's Council uh
Muller and councilor kaxton thank you
if you like to conduct the vote Bethany
thank you chair that but it's now in
progress
Council Norris do you want to give your
vote verbally
thank you chair those eight votes well
that's unanimous
questions by the public
none received
questions by councilors and then
received a chair
thank you
right we move on now to the meeting of
the meet of the meeting item seven joint
capital investment and treasury
management
I think that's for you to report Rebecca
please if you would
paper so take your time
certainly thank you chair and this
report
all investment and treasury management
strategies for 23 24. there have been no
significant changes in reporting
requirements or format for this year it
has been updated to reflect the latest
capital expenditure investment and
borrowing and the latest treasury
management investment and borrowing
positions of both councils
under the sit for treasury management
code of practice and the Prudential code
both published in 2021 and the
um do luck investment guidance published
in 2018 we are required to determine
separate capital investment and treasury
management strategy statements and
Prudential indicators annually before
the start of each Financial year there
are a number of appendices in the report
which I will just run through briefly
now for you appendix a is the capital
strategy so this summarizes the capital
expenditure and financing requirements
of the full Capital program for both the
general fund and the HRA the details of
the budget will be in the of the capital
budget will be in the budget report
this sets out capital expenditure and
capital investment decisions and the
associated risks and rewards along with
how risk is managed for future Financial
sustainability
it includes potential indicators which
demonstrate that the investment plans of
the councils are affordable prudent and
sustainable and decisions are made in
accordance with good practice
our strategy shows that expenditure plan
for 23.24 including carry forwards from
22-23 is 23 million for baber of which
14 million will be funded by borrowing
and 55 million for mid-suffolk of which
43 million will be funded by borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the Prudential indicators
the strategy demonstrates that projected
borrowing will not exceed these limits
appendix B is the investment strategy
this details those expenditure items in
the capital program that specifically
relate to assets bought and or owned by
the councils purely or partially to
generate a return
this includes schemes which have the
purpose of regeneration or development
of the local area as well as generating
return
in the context of this strategy
investments means non-treasury
management activities
find as two types of investment there
are those for service provision where
the council lends or buys shares in
organizations that provide a service
such as the Gateway 14 in mid-suffolk
which is for the purpose of regeneration
and economic development
there are also Investments purely for
yield where the primary purpose is to
generate a return such
cefco
this strategy explains how each
investment contributes to the council's
priorities and their security liquidity
and risk it shows the projected total
investment of the councils in sifco
growth companies and Gateway 14 and
planned expenditure on the council's
property held at least in part for
investment purposes
C is a treasury management strategy it
sets out the council's borrowing
requirement and treasury management
investment strategies this also includes
the list of approved investment
counterparties and limits there has been
no significant change to limits this
year
appendix day is the treasury management
indicators which we use to measure and
manage the council's exposure to
treasury management risks
appendix e is the economic update and
interest rate forecast
the ongoing impact on the UK from the
war in Ukraine together with higher
inflation higher interest rates on
certain government policy and it's
deteriorating economic Outlook will be
major influences on the council's
treasury management strategy for 2324
the authorities treasury management
advisor arning close is forecasting that
bank of England base rate will rise to
4.25 in the summer of 2023 and remain at
this level until spring 2024. long-term
borrowing pwb raids are forecast to
remain flat up until at least December
2025 with the 20-year rates forecast to
remain at around 4.65 and the 50-year
rate at around 4.4 throughout 2023 2024
and 2025.
appendix F shows the current investment
and debt portfolio as our 30th of
November 2022. the boring for baber is
113 million of which 94 million is pwlb
long term and 19 million in short term
for Midsouth at total boring is 135
million 99 which of which is long-term
and 33 million of which is short-term
on the investment side baber has 18
million invested and mid-suffolk 16
which includes the Council of strategic
pooled funds with ccla UBS Schroeder's
91 and funding Circle
appendix G shows the treasury management
policy statement this underpins the
strategy and sets out both councils
regard to the monitoring of risk and
performance and the primary objectives
remain security of capital then
liquidity followed finally by return
appendix H is the minimum Revenue
provision statement which shows the
basis on how we will put aside resources
to repay debt in later years there is no
change to this policy for 2023-24
and find the appendix eye shows the
institutions that were meeting the high
credit ratings criteria at November
we'll be happy to answer any questions
that you have on these strategies thank
you
thank you Rebecca um just a couple of
general ones from me before I opened the
floor you gave the overall debt for both
Council but that is mainly on the HRA
side I take it you didn't split them
apart is that correct
that is correct yes I think that they
are split apart in the in the report
um
as I remember it's about um
90 million on the baby side not too sure
on the mid-suffic side
it'd just be nice to make members
actually aware
sorry you're racing up
there's no prizes just just for
clarification
um so I have got a spreadsheet that's
got the split between the HRA and sifco
so if you're happy I'll just update you
with those numbers so for Mid Suffolk
the HRA element is about 69 million and
then for cifco it's 22 and a half
million
call up the baber
numbers so for Bay by the HRA loans are
just over 83 million and then for cifco
it's 11.25 million
83 for HRA thank you that is the
long-term debt as well isn't it yes
thank you
um and and the second one on page 29 the
pension debt um that seems to be getting
a little less could you just explain
there are some maybe some of the new
Council as um because it's uh 17 million
for baber
and 27 for Midsummer does that that
means that we're that far behind or is
it
the debt of where we want to be could
you just explain the figures there
please for me
I were previously but I know they have
come down significantly to what they
were at the last triennial valuation
we're that far behind on our
contributions for the deficit
right
and I say we're putting in half a
million so there's a catch-up program
in place because that's going to affect
us for many years to come isn't it
okay well thank you for clarification on
that writers are free for all now
councilor Castleton please thank you
very much Mr chairman if I um if I start
with appendix a
um
on page 19 capital expenditure and
financing
um 2.2
um individual assets costing below 10
000 are not capitalized and are charged
to our Revenue
um in in the year
um
what's what's the thought process behind
that 10
000 and is how is that is that in line
with what other
councils are doing I I do have um a
couple more questions but may I just ask
that one get the answer and then deal
with them one a time thank you
yeah thanks cancer Catherine for your
question
um yeah we do agree this with the
Auditors so it's one of our accountants
counting policies that we set out in our
statement of accounts
um I do know where stuff that we had the
same uh de minimis level 10 000 and I
think that is it's quite similar across
other councils
um you kind of go below that and it's
just not it's not worth capitalizing and
the effort to do it so that is that's
quite a consistent
um level to be set up
yeah that's a fantastic thank you
um the other um
one of the other questions was um we in
the HRA account
um do we have have I missed it in this
report the um the interest from the um
I forget what the fund's called but the
um the the fund that the Surplus from
the HRA has gone into in previous years
do we have a figure for that interest
rate that
that um the HRA would get from that
money
seven seven million or something in a
um I can't really yeah I can't remember
the name of the account but you you know
the one I'm talking about
um yeah no thanks for your question no
it's not actually detailed in this
report you will see that in the the
budget report there is an element of
interest that gets charged to the HRA
and so interest payable and interest
receivable it gets both of those
elements
um so you can see that in the budget
report but it's not specifically
mentioned in in this report here
and if there is a surface of deficit
that's dealt with through the Strategic
priorities reserving the HRA so that's
if there's a deficit we take it out of
that Reserve if there's a surplus we put
the money into that Reserve I think is
what you were yeah that's exactly what I
mean yeah no that's um good idea I would
quite like to see in here but if it's
not where it belongs then um it's not
where it belongs but it does help to um
see that and um just one final one Mr
chairman on um
[Applause]
in
the um hold on just let me find
[Applause]
um page 41
um table four total investment exposure
I would give you a chance to get to it
is that a duplication of that
um of the mid-suffic part of that
um table for because um we've got two
cumulative
exposures
um and figures are just slightly well
there's there's a difference in the
figures
um so is that a duplication I've seen
what's happened is it's been amended and
it's not been deleted but so is it the
last one that's the relevant one
we're just going to check the track
change document because I think you're
right I think that got updated and then
it didn't take out the original table so
yeah which we'll just have a look to see
if we've got the updated version too
I'm quite happy to let other people um
go in and have that in due course
chairman if that's going to take a
little while I don't know
just going back to your second question
councilor cast and is the interest on
the HR race something you think should
be shown here for us to deal with is
that what you were saying well I think
it's really quite relevant for that a
HRA account but whether it's relevant
for what we're doing here that it's in
it's an amount of interest that I'm
interested in which I think maybe is
relevant to this
but I don't know I'm prepared to like
take a lead from yeah I mean yeah
absolutely I mean we want these reports
to be as useful as possible and while we
do have the the kind of standard
template for Marlin close I think if
there's things that you'd like to see we
would like to build that in to help you
know with your reading and understanding
of the whole thing so if the interest
side of it is something you would like
to see we can certainly build that in
for next time thank you well I think we
should include that as a recommendation
really
yeah yeah thank you everyone is
available to that okay question number
three Rebecca yes please if I could just
come back on that that table for it is
the first table for the mid-suffic that
is the correct one
um so the one underneath should have
been deleted
wonderful thank you okay thank you for
that clarification counselor Yvonne
please
the chair I've got quite a lot of
questions but if I can first um just do
the few that are relating to the
assumptions on the on the initial um
report
um
at on page 12 at 4.4 it talks about
um the Strategic context of um
government
reducing core funding yeah I understood
that they've increased core funding
um this year and in fact the work the
letters RSG have crept back into um
the accounts
um so should that be
that is that correct that actual
paragraph
um
on
paragraph 4.13 but on page
um 14.
um it says at the last bullet point set
of revise and if there are material
changes present to full Council for
approval whereas I thought this had to
go to full Council for approval
regardless of whether there are any
changes or not
um and then on 11.1 again we refer to
this um things being discussed by the
climate change task Group which is no
longer in existence so that that needs
changing so if you could just
um
comment on the whether those three
points should be changed and at the same
time comment on the
um at 4.11 my question is could you just
give a bit more explanation about you
talk about the cash flow being impacted
by the timing of of Grant support
payments made to local businesses and
the receipt of support from central
government whereas I understood that we
were we got the money in that we
sorry excuse me that we're in a good
better position because we've already
got the money in before we were we were
um issuing it to businesses so if you
could just qualify that please thank you
see if I can get all of those answered
in the right order
um thanks councilor even for your
questions in terms of uh Government
funding
it's a little bit smoke and mirrors so
whilst we've had what they've called uh
Revenue support Grant received that was
already factored into Services Grants so
there was a council tax agencies Grant
and then there was another one as well
which we were already Banking and we'd
already had previously so whilst
government are saying they've increased
our funding actually it's pretty much
it's leveled off if not reduced slightly
so I I think that probably is still
still relevant
um the material changes I think that's
if it needs if anything changes during
the year so yes this does go through to
council for approval
um I think that paragraph is meant to be
referring to if something changes during
the year we will go back to council for
um material changes
um yes absolutely right you picked up
the the climate change one we need to
amend that at 11.1
and then in terms of cash flow time and
that's a real uh tricky one so yes we
did have uh the grants in for businesses
that we were sitting on we now have to
pay that back again now so there is a
timing element of that money going back
out of the councils but it's not just
relating to the business grants money we
had in there's a lot lots of other
things that we've had to pay out in
advance that we're still waiting for
reconciliations to be done to know
whether we've paid out more or less in
terms of some of these schemes so some
of it we did have up front and some of
it we had Top-Up payments um we've done
the reconciliation work to show how much
we much we paid out so there's always a
bit of a timing element in these things
a couple of them can I just come back on
that yeah so that the so because it says
it's impacted so it
the impact hasn't been that we've been
prevented from doing things or prevented
from
um so I kind of would just
you know trying to understand
you know what that sentence actually
means
it does say that the the cash flow has
been impacted by the time we have grants
and support payments so that's not
always necessarily a negative impact for
a a long period we were being able we're
able to defer going out to borrow
because we had a significant cash on our
balance sheet that we were holding in
advance of paying out covered grants to
organizations this year that has
reversed so where we've had that excess
cash we've had to pay pay some of that
back so we're starting to lose that that
benefit of being able to borrow from
those resources and having to go out
um to to borrow short term to replace
some of that that cash that was sitting
in the system that is now
now being being paid back back to
government
so we have had to borrow to
for some of that so that there was a
cost to that
yes yeah
okay
um just one question please
um on table one on page 20 the
um 23 24 budget for capital expenditure
mid-suffer 17.4 million I accept that
this obviously carries includes a carry
forward from 22-23 but can you tell me
how that figure has been made up please
because try as I may I can't get to
figure
yeah thank you
and it is have seen people a lot higher
than what we've had in the past and what
we've seen having in the future so I was
sort of stood out a particular figure
thank you for the question um I've just
got the capital program
um working paper up so um I'll just go
through so that
that line in the report is the capital
investment so that's investment in
companies and Loans to companies and So
within the mid-suffolk program
um there is a 10 million set aside for
Gateway 14. we're not anticipating that
we would necessarily need to use that
but we are keeping that in the capital
program and there's also 6.6 million to
Suffolk Suffolk Growth Company
um booked in there so I think 10.8 for
Gateway 14 and 6.7 for mint Suffolk
growth so that is is where the 17.4
comes from that's fine thank you Rebecca
thank you
Davis please yes I think Council reborn
has got more questions but please come
in first we just yeah we're just given
her a rest
oh boy
uh Rachel sometime then um I think it's
page 36. I
uh chair it refers to respecting EU
state aid rules
I think it's page 36
yeah it's probably on one of the
appendixes I don't
know
um are we still respecting EU state aid
rules
part of our strategy
the advice as to whether we are
yes thank you thank you for your
question
your creator we are no longer following
needing to follow the EU state aid rules
but there is a an equivalent
um B subsidy
do subsidy control
um but we that we do have to follow us
we will update that Within
everything
um then as sort of more I guess just
strategic sort of question
um you've said it would have mid-suffers
gonna need to borrow 43 million
um looking at the
um what's called
strategy for a maturity structure of our
borrowing at the moment we've got 30 30
percent of it on a one year
repayment basis when we're looking to
borrow our
43 million what sort of structure are we
looking to take on there
yes thank you thank you for that that
question yes you're right we do
currently have 30
um under 12 months within the maturity
structure
um a lot of that is because we've
borrowed short term for things such as
Gateway 14 and the growth companies on
anticipation of getting receipts back in
in the near term
um we do not yet know what maturity we
will be borrowing going forward
um 23 24
what we will be doing is we've set these
limits so that we are operating within
within these limits so that we're not
holding too much at any one one maturity
so we will be looking at this as that
need to borrowing materializes we will
look at the structure in advice in
consultation with our advisors aren't in
close to determine what periods that
would that would be for
foreign
loans
um to be honest I'm not I don't want to
jump into any long-term borrowing with
the rates so high at the moment so for
me personally I'd like to keep it short
term and just watch what happens with
those rates and once they start to come
down then I would be looking to lock
into some longer term borrowing but with
rates so high at the moment I don't
think it would be financially advisable
to jump into long-term borrowing with
them rates so high but it's a it's a you
know without a crystal ball it's really
difficult to know what to do but I don't
really want to tie us into a really high
rate if I think they're going to come
down in the future so we'll be talking
to Ireland close and looking at those
projections and as they change we can
then start to look to secure a lower
rate longer term
a reborn
um thank you chair on um page 22
um table
um at paragraph 2.13
mid-suffica scope that we're borrowing
um 22 24
25.6 million
um
and I just wondering why we're
why that's so high given the receipts
from Gateway 14 and again if it if
that's contrasted with the table on
um table three on the next page
where it's got a loan repayment of 26
million so if I could just have an
explanation on that and then
um
following on from that
the um on page 25
paragraph 4.4 when it refers to the
actual borrowing strategy it says the
councils Do Not borrow to invest for the
primary purpose of financial return but
we but we have done so
surely that should say will not be
borrowing
or just to make clear that it's not
because we have done in the past for for
um
Pacifico and then I've got a couple of
other questions but from
I'll leave you with those first thanks
yeah so the um the 25.67 that has come
down from currently where you are I
think you're short-term borrowing uh
before we had the Gateway 14 was that it
was written closer to 40 million but it
is higher than what we've had in terms
of capital receipt because of your new
capital program going forward so whilst
we're able to repay some of that
short-term debt we will need to borrow
some more in or as your Capital program
comes to fruition throughout the year
and that will put us back in a boring
position but not as high as where where
we were
um yeah I think we can make that a
little bit clearer that we will not be
borrowing going forward but you're right
you know we have before the rules
changed we had
um we had done that with Safeco so we'll
just make that clearer
that's great thanks very much and then
on page um
29 and 30.
um
the
I just was interested in the difference
between I think it's 7.2 the
um
the the difference between baber's um
costs gross costs for HRA and mid
suffolks I just wonder if you could just
give an explanation of of the of the
difference just
um
with a vibrational Ray is doing
something better than the mid-sufficient
one as it were and then
um following on from that at 7.4
are we saying that in order to um
are we are we saying that in order to
meet the capital kind of
strategy for the HRA
rents for mid-suffolk are going to have
to go up by those amounts
um whereas the baber wander
extremely I mean I know they're
different hras but I just you know the
contrast looks quite extreme on a table
on on 7.4 thank you
if I just answered the first question
um it might be helpful if I shared
outside of the meeting kind of the HRA
loans and the rates because there's a
number of HRA loans that were taken out
when we took on the debt for the council
houses and obviously we were two very
separate councils with two section 151
so actually the decision around the
borrowing you can see that the
difference in rates Mid-South Baba's
maximum rate was
um 3.42 and I think for mid-suffolk
they've got one is 7.88 another is 4.6
so it was the it was the section 151 at
the time took the decision to to look
into that thanks and I'm aware that the
actual
um kind of structure of the of loans
that baber was was very different and
and more um
short to medium term whereas I think
with suffix was spread over
more evenly spread over a longer term
period so but if that's the explanation
that's fine yeah okay and I'll never get
Rebecca yeah thank you so
um table 10 under 7.4 and this is one of
the Prudential indicators that that we
are required to do
um although it says the increase in
average
weekly rents that doesn't necessarily
mean that we will increase rents by that
amount
um it's all part of the overall HRA
picture and what this is um showing is
that for the capital program if all of
that was fine if that for the capital
program it's financed by borrowing what
is the the amount of weekly rent that
would be required to to pay those
financing costs
um so that is is where those figures
have come from
um for baber um a lot of the
Finance of their financing is coming
from Reserve so they don't have as much
borrowing which is why that indicator is
higher for mid-suffolk because there is
more borrowing to fund their Capital
program
so it's an equivalent indicator as
opposed to
kind of just
show it in a different light yeah yeah
okay that's good
I think the HRA debt and the percentage
what's been paid back should be the
subject of a separate chart almost it's
a bit difficult to pick it out to these
figures it does rather be combined
doesn't it
because I was in at the um scrap over
that to start with because I was against
it because we effectively brought back
the council houses that I thought we
owned anyway which was also
a very sore point with me as
a long while ago but it hasn't done us
any favors and sometimes it would be
nice
just to see how much we're getting this
um
debt down I knew it was about 90 million
and that's why I asked the original
question but it's hard to pick it out of
of these figures if you um save a domain
and I can see where country Reborns
question was coming from
councilor Castleton oh it was a comeback
on that
yeah I'm just trying to give you a break
because you're getting horse counselor
cast and I'll um I'll do a quick one
while I'm at 10-3 Ben rush and then she
can go for nine she's just got a lot of
questions she did warn me thank you very
much
um so in appendix c um page 48 it talks
about the Lobos the um lenders options
borrows options
um
Suffolk has um
two separate ones one running at four
point two percent interest the other one
4.22 interest
um
do we um
so with this you have a option if they
increase the interest to um either pay
back the um amount or um accept the new
interest rate
um do we have stroke need a policy on
that
um where um where we use the chem first
of all can we pay from reserves to
settle those loan amounts is is that
possible and do we have or need a policy
that means if that interest because
they've they've seen reasonably High
interest rates to me do we do we need to
look at the and get those settled
the minute they go they may have gone up
at some point and we didn't pay them
back I just if you could talk
so there's all sorts of questions
starting around but um yeah so basically
what I'm asking is has there been an
opportunity to pay that back that we've
not taken do we need a policy or have we
got a policy to pay them back if we need
them
just to just didn't clarify yeah no
problem thank you thank you for the
question um so yes so there are four
million of lenders option borrowers
options loans
um there there has been no no call on
those yet so um it's only when the
lender asks us or tells us that they
want to increase the rate we then have
the option to to say no thanks and walk
away
um because rates have been low and we're
only now sort of in that territory where
rates in the market generally are high
enough that there is more of a risk that
they will do that and we do not yet have
a policy for this and they have not
asked so far we would not have the cash
sitting in reserves necessarily and we
may have to go out to borrow to replace
these and we do have access to pwlb
borrowing and so we could
take that out to replace these if they
if they were called um
will be one of the options but we would
have to review in that instance what
cash position we were in if we had any
cash in Money Market funds that we could
could use to repay that but certainly
they have not made any indication that
they are calling them at this point
and wouldn't do by whatever means but
we're under different rules councilor
Davis please
thanks Sheriff uh on page top of page
52.
uh 0.5 11.
um
it has the first sentence there which
says that we've got incurred unrealized
Capital losses
uh the moment you say losses to me I
started getting a bit jumpy so are we
able to quantify well State when they
would be realized and what sort of level
are we looking at
yes yes thank you for the question
um So within um local government we have
a statutory override that means that
when these funds do drop in value that
that doesn't hit our Revenue budget so
there are some mitigations that we're
able to put through our accounts that
means these stay unrealized
um they have just extended that for a
further two years so we know that for 23
24 and 24 25 there will be no
requirement to to realize any of these
Capital losses
thank you and how big might they be
cool just bear with us because it's in
the half year report which neither one
of us have got open at the moment so if
you can just give us a few moments just
to find that
somebody else to jump in anyway just
take your time
um thank you thank you for your patience
yes I have I have that um for me now so
the councils have four funds
um there's a ccla
property fund so that has not got any
unrealized losses that is now in in
positive positive territory and there's
a Schroeder fund each Council
um the evaluation on that as at
um the end of September 2022 and was
about 600 000 so there's an unrealized
loss of six hundred thousand
um against a two million investment on
that for each Council
for and then there's a UBS fund
um similarly we're looking at about 0.5
um 0.5 and about
450 550 000 um on those at the moment
and then
um a 91 fund
um slightly higher valuation on those so
around about 250 000 unrealized loss on
each of those at the moment so until
it's around about 1.2
2 million quickly quickly adding those
together on only for each Council on
those
if you're a rapid work and I feel a
little more relaxed about that thank you
very much it's the future
thank you councilor reborn
um thank you very much chair on
page 39
um at the top 5.1 it the report talks
about
um both councils having some dependency
on profit generating investment activity
um
I think I feel quite strongly that that
should be worded separately for each
Council because you know at the end of
this financial year mid Suffolk will
have a surplus of four million pounds so
um
it clearly hasn't been dependent in
22-23 on on profit generating activity
so
um
I think that that
um you know I'll come on later to the
fact that I think potentially this
report should be separate for each
Council but
um
but that that statement doesn't really
tally with the regular sort of surpluses
we seem to be reporting
um then on um
on page 44 just to
um table 3.3
um
just if you could just you know it's one
of those tables that's um
could you just give a slight explanation
about the internal brackets over
borrowing cumulative and and just an
explanation of the terms in that
um you know I understand the CFO
and the external borrowing but just a
little bit more explanation on that one
thank you
yes thank you um page 39 yes we can um
certainly update that that wording to
reflect the the two different the
positions of the two councils and we'll
take that on board
um for the internal over borrowing
cumulative line on that report
um so when we talk about internal
borrowing that is is really the council
borrowing from its own reserves in in
cash terms and so we've got the CFR
which is our actual need to borrow
that's the capital program that we've
not yet financed from any other way and
but there's a because we've got
preserves in both councils and various
other areas of cash from from Seals
section 106 as well as the reserves that
we hold and we don't actually have to go
out externally to the market and borrow
for for all of that borrowing need and
so that that line is is internal
borrowing so that's the amount the
councils are effectively borrowing from
themselves
and and the cumulative is it cumulative
or is that
yes it is so it's it's the it's a
increasing amount
um chair I've got a couple of other
um
questions upon my on um
page 53 5.17
um
could you tell me how the monitoring of
the ESG
is actually happening
please
um that's at five
17 on page 53.
thank you
no I was I was actually having a look um
counselor even after
um Council the other night and I know
and we did have some indicators around
all of our investments that linked to
ESG but that was quite out of date now
so I think we probably need to update
that again
see where we're sitting
I think in terms of moving to an
investment fund that is more in line
with ESG I think I'm just a little bit
cautious at the moment with the way the
interest rates are going with me
suffolks need to borrow and also babers
need to borrow about any loss that we
might make and I think that was kind of
the recommendation that we would
consider it at the right time so I just
think everything has kind of gone
against us with interest rates going at
the moment and I think that's putting
more risk on both councils budget in
terms of Interest cost the budget for
next year even for mid-suffolk is going
up substantially so I need to have that
overall kind of look just to make sure
we don't shift into a lost position in
terms of where we are but certainly
updating those indicators is something I
want to I want to refresh those to see
where we're sitting in terms of our
funds because I know there's movement
happening in those funds around ESG so I
just want to see what work's been done
to to meet those requirements
if I can come back to you I mean that
whatever the decision that comes out of
it is is whatever the decision is as it
were but the point being how we actually
monitoring it so so that we can all see
what what monitoring is occurring which
members of the councilor are looking at
it and so on and so forth and and if if
a decision a or decision B is made
that's
that's how you know that's that's making
the decision but it's just at the moment
we can't see where that monitoring is
happening so if those indicators can be
updated that would be
um
that'd be really helpful
I've got a couple more questions to
share but I'll let someone else
yeah this issue is it yes far away thank
you sure yes it is yes it was a proposal
really uh can we establish
our Benchmark where we are at the moment
when it comes to uh this ESG on our
investments
and then moving forward we can send in
place of strategy because I if we
understand correctly our councils are
committed to
um Net Zero by 2030 which
which put in place a strategy which
gets us there and allows us to decide
whether or not we're prepared to Pace
like a higher interest for things which
may benefit Humanity rather than
short-term gain
yes I just got to mention this as well
because we're all aware that for the May
meeting none of us may be here it would
be um quite good to
um just establish a line
maybe a paper at the next meeting to
show what's been done and the way
forward and and where we are and and
what funds might be the first one to
change a bit because we need to do the
right thing financially and the right
thing in our environmentally and it is
it is a balance isn't and we're well I'm
aware of that as chair
I want to do the right thing but not put
us in debt doing it you see
so thank you for raising that um cancer
reborn and Davis but
yeah I'd certainly like to take that
away and come back with kind of kinds of
risks and
proposals around that so that you've got
something to have a look at for
considered kind of
thank you
um councilor castan thank you um a quick
one um on internal boring do we have any
interest mechanism with that or is that
just moving money
so um yes generally
um there's no no interest on that
effectively we are saving each Council
saving interest by not not going out out
to the market and the one instance where
there is is between the HOA and the
general fund so if we are
if the general fund is effectively
borrowing from the HRA or pay the HRA
interest on that and vice versa through
that charging mechanism because they're
two separate ring fans
I was just checking um the um
with the um
got a bit of an echo but oh it's gone
now
um the um with the money market funds
um it we have a small fee charged for
professional for a professional fund
manager
um do we have that amount
um could that be made available please
please it just says small fee which
I'm sure it is but I'd quite like to see
an actual cost
of that
um and also the
a lot of what Arlington close
does there'll be costs associated with
and that I
it's not necessarily obvious within this
um paper
um
and finally this is some
just a bit of a
statement
um we've got this um table one the
interest rate forecast which is in
Arlington close document I'm sure and um
you you might not be able to comment on
it because this is something that
they've supplied to you
um
with the um
the central case rates the um
the the money market rate and the um and
the guilt
rights don't seem to be um that
different and to me they should be there
should be quite a lot of difference
between those two um figures but I do
wonder if um we might need Arlington
close to or I might need Arlington Place
to educate me on
on those figures because they're they're
included they're quite important but
as far as I'm concerned the guilt
um yields should be a lot lower than the
money market funds
um so um and they there doesn't seem to
be that much difference but that's just
a statement and I do wonder if um at
some point Arlington Place may be able
to um help me and anyone else that needs
it out with those
do we pay Arlington close a retainer
overall or do we pay them ad hoc for
what they do and if so how much is that
right James yeah
to be in this report
it'll be somewhere that maybe not
obviously not in this report but Rebecca
will tell us I'm sure yes I think yeah
we do pay an annual fee to our enclosed
which will be published on our contracts
register
um but yes that's what should really be
in the public domain so I don't think
there will be an issue with with
so um what title would that be under
within the um the the budget when we we
do come to it
just from memory without looking at the
budget book I think it's under corporate
resources and it'll be either contract
payments or supplies and services but it
will be kind of lost in with with other
yeah of course of course yeah you can't
list we don't want to pay for quite that
large but as Rebecca said is published
on our contracts register as well so
that information is in the public domain
yeah perfect thank you
counselor yes I thought you had some in
reserve floor is yours
um thank you chair on page 58
um with the tertiary indicators the
target of seven for the average credit
score
um
mid-suffix on 5.35 have we ever where
does that Target come from as it were
and um
have we ever met it
or are we likely to or is it you know
reasonable thank you
I think we probably just need to go away
and just look at the calculation that
sits behind that just without I don't
want to give you information without
double checking how that's calculated
and also looking back to see where we
sit in terms of that Target as well so
if that's okay we'd like to just take
that one away yeah thanks for that and
it'll be quite interested you know
not saying I want you to do a load of
research on it but in terms of other
councils because if nobody else is if we
set sit around the same as everyone else
then it's not
anything that you know in terms of
thinking about you know AAA Investments
and so on
um
you know I don't want to be worrying and
Julie about things
and then
um
on page
70 I think we always have a um
discussion about
um the um
minimum Revenue provision and just
um
I was just wondering whether it's worth
you know when you did your introduction
in terms of the kind of
you know what funds are needed for that
um
how that has you know changed or
um you know if they can give a bit more
explanation on that against the um CFR
please because I think those are again
in terms of looking at these audit
reports those are terms and factors that
are quite different from looking at
budgets thank you chair
I'll kick off and then if um if Rebecca
wants to jump in at any point
um so in terms of MRP so every time we
have a borrowing requirement in the
capital program come forward we always
build in MRP with that as well
um so it's always a budget that we set
aside and it's always the following year
from when capital expenditure is spent
so we do make sure we build that into
the um into the budget setting every
time as I say a capital expenditure item
that is funded from borrowing
um comes forward
um just because there another part of
your question counseling sorry
it was just a relationship between the
MRP and the CFR
um really and just ensuring that we
understand clearly what
um the report is laying out
yep so as you as your CFR increases the
element that's coming from borrowing is
then related to the MRP so the capital
element of that borrowing is what your
MRP is effectively so as you'll see a
file increases if it's being funded from
borrowing you'll see your your MRP going
up as well to to match that
is there anything you wanted to add
more technical yeah it's also um just
worth noting that we don't have to make
MRP on the HRA so it's only on the
general fund fund part of it
any other questions
from anyone we've given this up fairly
thorough
um
working over and I think most all the
questions I had have been asked either
by me or other people
I am aware we've made one or two sort of
requests haven't we
um which I'm sure Bethany has taken in
the minutes and will show up if I could
ask you Jan is it okay that we just act
on them through being in the minutes we
don't have to list them separately in
the vote do we
no chair we can take those away as
actions and we'll have an action tracker
to make sure that those are reported
back to the next committee that would be
brilliant so um
yeah we need a little bit of breakdown
for the HRA which is what I ask for
um plus the ESG that was sort of
and um cancer reborn wanted splitting up
the um I'm I'm not quite sure but I
think you you've actually picked that up
haven't you yeah yeah casual casting
um I don't know um what the mid-suffer
councilors think about this but
obviously it's not relevant to baby
councils
um because they don't have the Lobos but
um I do I wouldn't mind a recommendation
to consider a policy and event that an
presents itself on the Lobos and where
the money would come from to um deal
with those
um but I'm quite happy for that to be
done in the same way without a condition
attached to the proposal okay well I saw
that here and I didn't quite understand
that but that's that's a bit Suffolk um
yeah that's why you don't you because it
is relevant to baber because you don't
have any
um but I think for for mid-suffic with
the Surplus that we're running
um and to have debt that's the interest
is at that level that that's something
that I'd like I'd like to us to look
into before the opportunity presents
itself
or that that strategy to be considered
but um
I'd also like to like thank the officers
involved with this because um I was
saying earlier that um they've obviously
been one down and going through this and
as I was saying earlier that I
I'll check my emails or be working late
at night and I'll quite often see that
they're still logged on and working away
so there's been a huge amount of work
that's gone into this and I'd like to
thank them for um
what they've done but do you need a
proposer I will do in a moment no I've
got cancer reborn wishes to speak I
believe
unless she's going to propose it as well
um thank you very much chair I just
wanted to make a point that
um when um there was the corporate peer
review the
um councilors on that review were
surprised that we had a joint audit
committee and that um
it wasn't separate for each Council and
I've got a concern that there are
differences between the
the differences between the the baber um
finances and mid-suffolks are such that
the the officers write in the report
have either got to constantly be doing a
separate paragraph for each or um you
can't generalize between the two
um and I think it needs to be very clear
you know some of the points that I've
picked up
um that only apply to one councilor not
the other and therefore we should
um you know should we be actually
looking at a separate report or separate
committee
um
um secondly we had in the past
um talked about a visit from about Arden
close actually coming to speak to the
committee and that was talked about some
time ago but that's not happened in my
as far as I'm aware
um and we'd also talked about training
for
um audio and I appreciate we've come to
the end of the council term and I'm I'm
that will be in the in the next
um
you know with the new counselors that
are coming in but I think that's
something that really needs to to be in
place and perhaps with the Island close
um one at the same time
um and I must say I'm surprised that
none of the finance portfolio holders
are here today
um which I just find
um
you know given the comments we had at
mid-suffolk Council this last week that
I'm surprised that they haven't come to
this committee
um but finally the with regards to the
recommendations in the report I I can't
vote for them unless I I'm assured that
there's going to be that these are going
to be amended
with all the comments that have been
made so
um because as it stands I'm not
confident to
you know
um you know the things that we've picked
up on or that we want to see changed
um I would like to see them in the
report going to
full Council and so I I
if there isn't a recommendation stating
that or somehow that's included then
then I'm afraid I won't be able to vote
for it
the chair
okay well all I report on these two baby
District Council and it goes to
mid-suffolk council you want more than
that
sorry what did you
um all these reports of meetings go to
the respective
councils mid-suffolk and baber so
they're open for debate again there and
for changing after we've dealt with them
yes but I'm saying that this that that
this committee here has has gone through
this report and we have all you know
some of us have made suggestions on what
should be changed and the officers have
agreed or or clarified or whatever and
that those changes therefore should be
included in the report that goes to
council otherwise I'm not going to sit a
council and go through all of this again
um because that's so I would like to so
this recommendation has got to be that
the following be approved with
amendments made by the committee kind of
thing otherwise you know I don't want to
kind of sit and say well you know
go through all these points again
because otherwise what's the point of
this committee well at the moment we've
agreed to take it forward with
recommendations
um or there could be amendments I can't
certainly read it's no no different
either way can I just assist so we can
easily put a recommendation in to say
sub
amendments and some comments that were
and what we can do is make sure that we
get those minuted and circulated to
committee to make sure we've actually
absolutely captured everything
um subject to those amendments and
comments been added into the report that
the report is is agreed approved to go
to
um thank you that's yeah that's the more
type of thing that I was thinking of
thank you very much for that
that's the four more formal approach
you'll be happy with that yep okay well
let's um said it done
you were
I think that's been sorted out I was
going to agree with councilman and I
think she's made a very sensible um
recommendation there so we either do it
sort of um
formally so it's it's formally then yes
okay you will need to have a proposal
and a secondary to agree that Amendment
and then we can put it straight to to
the vote if that's okay that's part of
the main vote yep that's fine that's
what I thought Angela Davis yes
sorry just gonna do actually have Jen's
invitation into the proposed okay well
obviously we are we are meant to have a
debate after we've had all the questions
so
personally I can't tell the difference I
think we've had both in one go but has
anyone got anything else to
um to say and then we'll formally go to
the well we'll we'll have degree the out
of meeting bit first and then it'll
become that substantive vote but
anything else a debate or a question
yeah I just want to add that it is a
very very complex
um set of papers and I think you know we
we do really appreciate the time that
goes into to doing them but I think it's
really important that we ask
the questions and get it as
um yes as right as we can do and and
make sure that we all understand Andy
but I'd like to say thanks that I know
councilor custard mentioned it earlier
but to say thanks to the officers
particularly
um on that front and and if we could you
know at some point consider whether we
have separate audit committee but um
I'll leave that one for
after may maybe let's say
that will be something for the next
councils around it and um I think the
officers would probably like to move the
other way but that would be for others
to decide
so um proposal that the three things I
think it was three were mentioned uh is
my request to have the HRA figures
picked out the ESG and the and the one
that was three wasn't there oh and and
sorry Taylor did the low voters
mentioned separately didn't you yeah
I I wish I could remember that um the
the previous year yeah
but that was yours um councilor Cason
no no mine was something separate I
wanted to see the debt split between HRI
and the general fund so we could see
which was application are pertaining to
which um to which funds you see that was
the first question I asked which I think
is quite reasonable otherwise if it's
all lumped in together
um it's hard for us
um to differentiate yours was something
a bit different wasn't it would you like
me to just try and clearly say exactly
what that was or do we know I think we
know look we've got copious note yeah
and we've got also the recall
record on that so I think chair I think
it's reasonable to just say subject to
the
um comments the Amendments and the
comments from the committee being
um added to the report before it goes to
council for approval
and we can take a vote on that
information yes we we just need to
propose in a second to agree the um
Amendment to the recommendations and
then we can go straight to the main vote
that's right well I'll propose
everything that was said and look for a
second definitely is uh councilor Miller
school chair yeah that's fine so that's
done and that will be added and we'll
get to see them
and now if we can move Bethany to the
substantive vote
and while we learn that
thanks for me I know how hard you work
and it's horrible at the moment Finance
isn't it um it's not great it's not easy
it's between a rock and a hard place and
we are appreciative of that and what you
do
and that that will be minuted as well
I'm sure
thank you chair that way it's now in
progress
so that's unanimous
well done everybody
moving on to the complaints report and
I'm sure there's coffee outside
somewhere for our um
our offices if they're leaving us now
and you're presenting this Jan not yet
not IFD as I assumed you would yep far
away thanks chair so this is the regular
report that comes from the monitoring
officer dealing the number of complaints
and for this period it's from the 1st of
May 2022 to the 17th of January oh it
should be 2023
um it details the number of complaints
we receive the breakdown against
district and Parish councils the number
of complaints upheld findings of no
breach and the findings where there is a
breach I'm happy to take any questions
um on that if counselors have any
thank you
as always babes him to be worth behaving
than midsummers like me don't they but
um I think chair that can be quite
misleading sometimes because if you have
a
say a parish council where there's an
issue we might get multiple complaints
about the same issue so
um that can be a bit deceptive but yes
baber does tend I'm afraid to have more
complaints Parish wise and yeah
grumbly Parish councils I'm aware of yes
cancel Augustine
um I'm not sure if I ask this every time
and to get the same answer but um where
um we have say it made Suffolk and six
complaints against Parish councils could
that be the same Parish Council that six
times or is that it could certainly be
the same Parish Council but it's it is
six different complaints and we might
receive six complaints you know from
members of the public and maybe a couple
of councilors who are at the meeting as
well so um you know it can look worse
than what it actually is so that could
potentially be one meeting where six
people saw something that wasn't
acceptable or they they thought okay
yeah thank you
anything else from anybody else
Chad can I just add some comments there
I just wanted to say that ongoing we've
had the new code of conduct there's new
Suffolk code of conduct
um which um parishes and and town
councils and District agreed there is
some still some confusion out
specifically in the parishes around
Declarations of interest and that um has
caused some problems where councilors
haven't declared interest when they have
been seen by members of the public
particularly to
um you know where they should have done
and so we are going to make sure that
come May that that code of conduct
training is very thorough and extensive
and goes out almost immediately and so
that councilors are fully briefed
it's the new the new councilors tend not
to like it sometimes and yeah I'm used
to that okay well this is for noting
which we have done and will do and
forward plan
last item on the agenda this morning
the mola will be chair next time around
and that'll be the last one okay sorry
can I just interrupt there is a change
needed to the forward plan the statement
of counts will now be in July not March
okay
okay is that because they're just not
finished they're behind schedule I take
it isn't
yes the Auditors will be with us in
muster in the 20 20 21 audit so they
won't have completed their work when but
in time for that committee so
unfortunately we'll have to go to the
July committee
yes I'm well used to that on The Wider
Circle everybody is um behind but it's
not great
that's not going to impact anything I
mean I know every council is in the same
position aren't they because they're so
behind but that won't impact any of the
anything day to day or even long term
will it
it will put pressure on the team and
also we're trying to put in the new
financial management system as well so
we may have to get additional resources
to help us do year-end or respond to
Auditors queries because obviously the
team will then be working on getting the
financial management
side so it will have internal resource
implications for us
am I right and thinking that business
can't you can't be behind but Local
Government Can is that correct
yeah there's no penalties now for for
late audit sign-offs wouldn't we yeah
that's the world we're living in I'm
afraid of ordered it's not great
thank you everybody
meeting close
see you on the 27th of March
27th of March
put it in your diary because we're a bit
light sometimes but good to see both
councils and
your staff